what up peeps i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message we are in
florida in boca raton to be specific at
the newsmax studios for two more days
then i move to my new home we build a
makeshift studio that will be in for
about a month while we build out the
bigger studio
and uh it's all going to work itself out
all good things are good here i'm
feeling good about life uh as always we
are on youtube rumble and blaze tv
subscribe tap notification bells
whatever it is that you do do it why not
why not uh all right we got four stories
for you today i tried to mix it up a
little bit there was a really really
interesting hearing yesterday you know
these congressional hearings when people
talk about stuff but usually much
doesn't happen and it's a lot of just
endless blather well there was a really
interesting moment with ted cruz uh
talking about the january 6th
insurrection and wait a minute is it
possible that the fbi had something to
do with it and that they had plants in
the crowd that maybe instigated some of
the violence we've got video you'll see
then joe biden's ratings his approval
ratings have just completely completely
cratered basically at about 33
percent right now 33 of the people who
approve of old joe this is a man who of
course we are told got 81 million votes
the most votes ever
for a president of the united states and
now only a third of americans approve of
what he's doing i'd like to examine
that third of people because uh it
really should be even less than that but
it really is pretty terrible so we'll
talk about that uh and then that'll be a
sort of good segue into the third story
which is kamala harris was interviewed
on nbc
yesterday and uh she was asked are they
thinking about 2024 and of course she
gives a deeply dishonest answer so we'll
play some video on that and now there's
rumors and it's starting to
uh come up through the internet that
this woman you may have heard of her
hillary clinton i had to do a little
googling on her uh she may run in 2024
so we found some old video once i
realized who she was i had long
forgotten of course
we found some video of her questioning
the results of the 2016 election you
might find that interesting and then
finally we'll do a little bit
of covid stuff uh specifically about dc
where they are demanding that everyone
be vacs to go out and mask to go out and
now it's kids and a whole bunch of other
stuff this of course is the mayor coming
from the mayor of dc bowser who
she herself a few weeks ago you know she
was downstairs in a nightclub dance and
having a good time but you know she just
wants your kids to be vaccinated the
whole thing and then we found a really
great compilation video online of just
how the narrative has been just
absolutely collapsing that's really the
theme of this whole week more than
anything else is that so much of the
stuff that for two years they told us
was not only true but we couldn't
question it well now we're all
questioning it it's all crumbling in
front of all of us and this gives us a
chance to wake up more people so
some good things on the horizon before
we get to any of that though i want to
talk to you find people about genusell
ladies and gentlemen the new year is
upon us that means there's a chance to
make 2022 your best year ever and with
genusel by shamini you can look 5 10
even 15 years younger it's hard to pick
one thing i like most about their
products it could be their lightweight
feel how smooth they make my skin feel
or even their fresh scent their
crystallus microdermabrasion treatment
smells like orange citrus during the
genusel new year's clearance event save
over sixty percent off janusel's
hand-picked most popular package to take
care of all your skin care needs see
yourself with those uh fine lines
forehead wrinkles sagging jawline and
even those under eye bags gone works for
both women and men safe for all skin
types and perfect for skin of any age
shamany promises results that will make
you smile guaranteed or a hundred
percent of your money back go to
lovegeniusel.com dave to save over 60
off their most popular package every
order is automatically upgraded to free
priority shipping don't wait go to
lovejanusell.com
dave that's love g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave and now back to me
all right one of the things i often talk
about on this show is the dog and pony
show that were often shown in congress
right they haul all these people in
front of congress people kind of say
things under oath no one ever gets
really taken to task on anything it's a
lot it's a lot of show but we have had
some nice moments over the last couple
months related to these congressional
hearings when it's come to big tech some
things have come to light uh
particularly some of the videos that
we've all seen with rand paul getting
into fights with anthony fauci it's like
even if these people aren't you know
arrested let's say or or prosecuted for
lying under oath when they do lie under
oath as anthony fauci obviously does at
this point
at least it gets some people out there
to see these viral clips where you can
then hopefully pilfer some truth out of
it well you may remember the january 6th
2021 insurrection that lasted for a few
hours there was the guy who maybe had a
lego set of the capital there was the
guy with the horn hat and the face mask
and you know the whole thing and it was
over real quick aoc thought she was
going to be killed she made it out okay
yadda yadda
basically liz cheney who's a republican
and then the democrats have this january
6 committee they want to figure out how
this insurrection happened and we have
to take down these people a whole bunch
of other stuff but there was a really
really interesting exchange
with ted cruz talking to the fbi's jill
sanborn about possible involvement by
the fbi in the insurrection itself take
a look i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidential informants actively
participated in the events of january
6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6.
yes or no yes or no sir i can't i can't
answer that
did any fbi agents or confidential
informants commit crimes of violence on
january 6
6
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6.
sir i can't answer that on the night of
january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered and there's video out there
of him chanting tomorrow we need to get
into the capitol into the capitol
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting fed fed
fed fed fed fed
miss sanborn was rehabs a fed
sir i cannot answer that question
okay this is really an extraordinary
exchange ted cruz is being very very
specific
with his language ted cruz who of course
is a harvard trained lawyer
being very very specific did fbi agents
participate or did confidential
informants participate in any violent
acts
and she will not answer i'm sure you can
appreciate that i can't tell you the
truth i might work for the government
what do you think i'm supposed to be
doing here um but
the way she's saying it
let's pretend for a moment that they did
that the fbi actually seeded people out
into the crowd now the fbi has work to
do i understand that they have work to
do and i actually understand at some
level although this is getting hard to
explain at this point because our
government is so out of control i can
understand at some level that the fbi
can't be fully open about every single
thing that they do right the cia mi6
mossad they can't tell you every single
thing that they're doing right there has
to be a little bit of a lack of
transparency they got agents they got
double agents there's a whole bunch of
other stuff okay fine so let's just put
that aside for a second
if the fbi was putting people into that
crowd to instigate violence which is
basically what ted cruz is asking
uh talking about that eppsky
specifically maybe he was involved maybe
he wasn't it's unclear right uh but if
there were people there that maybe we're
pushing people towards oh yeah yeah yeah
let's break into those windows oh oh oh
yeah i've got some rocks here i've got
whatever a baseball bat who the hell
knows there actually weren't that many
weapons there so maybe not that but if
they just seated the crowd with people
that were like yeah let's attack the
capitol let's go in make sure the doors
are open we all have seen the videos of
the officers just moving barricades and
just letting people in and officers
talking to the people as they walk into
the capitol saying just don't be violent
could you guys stay within the the
bounds here which by the way a lot of
people did i mean it was a very strange
insurrection nobody brought a plan you'd
think somebody would have a piece of
paper guys the plan uh we're going to
take over the capitol three hours in and
then we do we have no there's no plan
bob what about the plan forgot to plan
um the fact that she can't answer that
is sort of the the exact example of how
out of control government has got as i
said i'm willing to grant government a
little bit of
leeway here i'm granting the agencies a
little bit of leeway that they have to
do certain things to make sure bad guys
don't don't do so that really bad guys
don't do horrible things right
um but
if they were involved in this thing and
now they've basically used their power
to turn against american people or
manipulate american people this is
deeply deeply dangerous by the way this
is the same fbi that we know plotted
to kidnap
michigan governor gretchen whitmer to
make it look like you know these white
supremacist insurrectionists were up to
bad news bad stuff so it's like we know
that they do these kind of things so i
thought this was this is worth seeing
because it's the type of thing that
there is no chance in high hell that cnn
or msnbc or mainstream media is going to
cover that moment
um but we're allowed to ask questions as
to what happened there so good for ted
cruz you know i know ted cruz had a bit
of a i like ted cruz obviously he had a
bit of a rough week because you know he
had this moment
sort of off the cuff where he said this
thing about how january 6 was a
terrorist attack then tucker carlson
took him to task on that he made an
interesting point of saying that he's
always described any political act of
violence as a terrorist attack whether
it's antifa blm burning down cities or
anyone that did any violent thing there
so he walked it back a little bit um so
i think he did a nice job there i have
no problem with ted cruz and nobody's
perfect so there you go but if
our intelligence agency cia and fbi are
working against us and if they are out
there in crowds it's like what else are
they doing what else are they doing
good question dave thank you
all right let's talk about old joe biden
because that whole insurrection thing
that i just talked about that
insurrection thing uh was about the
election of joe biden and uh 81 million
people that's what they told us voted
for joe biden that's an awful lot of
people it's actually the most people
that ever voted for a president in the
history of the united states and if you
don't remember the second most people
that ever voted for president united
states were donald trump in the exact
same election he got about 75 million
votes according to what they tell us and
i don't want to be kicked off youtube
for even saying that some of that may be
a little fudged i don't know um but
biden's approval numbers are absolutely
in the tank right now we've got a tweet
here from tom bevin biden job approval
in a new quinnipiac poll is 33 among
adults and just 25
with independence among registered
voters
it's 35
i mean this is
extraordinarily low like this is like
just like bananas low and if you think
about it think how soft the media has
been on him right there's really no
criticism of joe biden in mainstream
media really just try to think for a
second has nbc abc cbs cnn all the usual
suspects have they done anything really
critical of him guy you know he was
going to shut down the virus then two
weeks ago oh no there's nothing i can do
kick it back to the states which by the
way is what the orange guy wanted the
entire time like he has failed at every
possible level we're at about 10 i think
it's 9.7 percent inflation right now and
it's like that that is an incredibly
high number people don't realize that
means in essence you have 10 percent
less money right if you have 500 bucks
and inflation goes up by 10 you're
losing 50 bucks now you got 450 bucks in
essence the number in your bank account
may be the same but it doesn't have the
same value like we know that the thing
ain't working that sort of sounds like
joe biden you know man the thing ain't
working okay well
it ain't working and even here in
florida where things are pretty damn
good you can see some of the residual
stuff related to
supply chain we went into two targets to
buy some stuff for our new house we
needed some plates just temporarily
while our stuff comes from la we need
some plates couple other things and
there were a lot of barren shelves there
really were not like massively massively
empty here florida's obviously doing a
better job moving some stuff and they're
getting people to work but it wasn't it
wasn't perfect here but 33 is
extraordinarily low especially for a guy
that you know got these 81 million votes
people are actually waking up despite
the media protecting the guy and of
course you would just have to contrast
that with how the media treated orange
man who i'm pretty sure michael maybe
you could check on this what was donald
trump's lowest ever approval rating i
think it floated around 40 percent
despite endless attacks on him right so
the media was always going after trump
and i think he floated around 40 now
you've got biden around 33 despite like
some pretty great coverage so i'll see
if we can get that number in just a sec
but i thought you know what we played
this clip yesterday
where we contrasted some of
ron desantis state of the state speech
with some of joe biden's best hits and
as we were putting together the
compilation of joe biden we watched the
full corn pop video you all remember the
corn pop video joe biden at the pool
talking about the thing well we watched
it and i was like you know we have to
show this full video to people it's so
insane it's just so absolutely insane
and this moment this two or so minute
video that we're about to show you this
should have derailed his entire thing
people should have watched this video
and said this man is clinically insane
and should not be president let's go i
learned a lot
and i learned that uh it makes a
difference this was the driving board
area
and i was one of the guards
and they weren't allowed it was a three
meter board and you fell off sideways
you landed on the dams uh the darn
cement over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed
one of the things you had to use if you
use pomade in your hair you had to wear
a bathing cap
and so he was up on the board one
listening i said hey esther you
off the board i'll come up and drag you
off
well he came off
and he said i'll meet you outside my car
this was mostly these were all public
housing behind it
my car there was a gate out here i
parked my car outside the gate
and i he said i'll be waiting for you
who's waiting for three guys in straight
razors
not a joke
there's a guy named bill wright mouse
the only white guy and he did all the
pools he was the mechanic
and i said what am i going to do he said
come down here in the basement where
mechanics where where all the pool
filter is you know the chain there used
to be a chain that went across the deep
end and he cut off a six foot length of
chain he fold up he said you walk out
with that chain
and you walk to the car and say you may
cut me man but i'm going to wrap this
chain around your head
i said you kidding me
he said no if you don't don't come back
and he was right
so i walked out with the chain
and i walked up to my car
and they had those days used to remember
the straight razor razors bang them on
the curb get them rusty put them in a
rain barrel get them rusty
and i looked at them but i was smart
then i said first of all i said when i
tell you get off the board you get off
the board i'll kick you out again but i
shouldn't have called you esther
williams i apologize for that
i apologize but i know that apology is
going to work he said you apologize to
me i said i apologize for that not for
throwing you out but i apologize for
what i said
he said okay close the straight razor my
heart began to beat again
i hope you enjoyed that because as many
times as i've seen it it makes less
sense each time and as a matter of fact
i thought let's play a little game with
this thing
if any of you
within three sentences can explain what
joe biden was saying right there
i will give you 500
that's what i'm going to commit to doing
if you can explain that in a sane
functional non-jokey non-sarcastic way
if you can tell me what joe biden was
saying there with the roaches and the
leg hair and corn pop and the cement etc
etc i will give you 500 american dollars
you can submit
your
explanations at reubenreport.locals.com
three more years abiding and then we'll
be okay so there you go uh but
will there be three more years of joe
biden uh it's very unclear actually
because joe biden's vice president
kamala harris she was on nbc being
interviewed about what perhaps
they might do in 2024 are they going to
stick it out and keep going is she going
to take over what's going to happen have
they even thought about it are we going
to uh to see the same democratic ticket
in 2024
i'm sorry we are thinking about today i
mean honestly that i i know why you're
asking the question because this is the
part of the punditry and the the gossip
around places like washington dc let me
just tell you something we're focused on
the things in front of us
we're focused on what we need to do
to to address issues like affordable
child care what we need to do
conversations about 2024.
the american people sent us here to do a
job and right now there's a lot of work
to be done and that's my focus it sounds
sincerely you're at least familiar with
some of the punditry i don't know if
you've heard that there have been some
there's been some talk about a a a bind
cheney ticket perhaps in 2024 did you
read that article i did not i
no i did not and i really could care
less
about the high-class gossip on these
issues
okay first off everything she said there
was a lie they obviously are thinking
about it they're obviously talking about
it this is what politicians do you get
into power and then you figure out how
you can stay in power so of course she's
lying and anyone that says that they're
not thinking about their next election
is always lying she also said she could
care less which she means is she
couldn't care less that's one of my
biggest pet peeves you know she couldn't
care less if you couldn't care less you
can't care about it any less i don't
care about it all but he says well uh
biden might run with liz cheney i could
care less oh so you do care
i just can't stand that it drives me
nuts um also i haven't read that article
about biden maybe running with liz
cheney but does that tell you everything
you need to know about liz cheney she's
not a real republican obviously she's a
democrat
she's awful
anyway
there is a chance now that hillary may
get into the race that's the new talk
because basically what's happening is
that when you look at biden's approval
numbers and his age and his cognitive
decline and everything else and then you
couple it with a woman who was polling
at zero percent in her own party like
nobody there simply is nobody that
supports kamala harris there is just
nobody out there there yes media people
put stories about her but there is no
average human being that
that is supporting kamala harris so the
democrats have to figure out what to do
right so now suddenly there's all these
stories popping up will hillary get back
in the race uh we've got a little info
here from the new york post could a
third time be the charm for hillary
clinton that's the case made by two
prominent democrats who claim a perfect
storm of president biden's plummeting
job approval ratings vice president
kamala harris's own unpopularity and the
commander-in-chief's advanced age could
provide an opening for the former first
lady and the secretary of state she is
already in an advantageous position to
become the 2024 nominee democratic
nominee political consultant doug shone
and former manhattan borough president
andrew stein write in wednesday's wall
street journal of the 74 year old
clinton she is an experienced national
figure who is younger than mr biden and
can offer a different approach from the
disorganized and unpopular one that the
party is currently taking they had if
democrats lose their house and senate
majorities in november's midterms
schonenstein argue clinton can
capitalize on the losses as a basis to
run for president again enabling her to
claim the title of change candidate okay
let me just say the article is mostly
nonsense because 74 and she's going to
be the change candidate yes hillary
clinton is going to come in and be the
change candidate and she's so young at
24 right like at 74.
man we could use a 24 will be can't be
president of 24 year old uh but
it was making me think it was making me
think why would hillary run now we know
she's lost twice but it's not just that
there might be some other reasons she
might not run i mean does hillary
clinton believe in the validity of our
previous elections we've got a
compilation
you know every time donald thinks things
are not going in his direction he claims
whatever it is is rigged against i know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level this is this is how donald thinks
and it's funny but it's also really
troubling i believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons why the election turned out the
way it did he's an illegitimate
president
and because of that he is
he's he's very uh insecure about it of
course he's obsessed with me oh hillary
i'm sorry i probably ruined all your
lunches but i haven't even listened to
that ridiculous woman um but it's just
interesting to know that you know when
the democrats question election validity
when they say that someone's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
something happened he knows what was the
other one uh that the election it wasn't
on the level of course she's talking
about the election that she lost
remember you're allowed to do stuff when
you're a democrat you cannot do it when
you're republican or anyone who isn't
just sort of a brainwashed blue-pilled
npc
person so in some weird way doesn't it
feel like this whole thing will end with
a hillary
uh trump rematch like it sort of feels
like that like the biden thing the
wheels are just coming off it's just
completely crumbling and then it's like
where are the republicans gonna go you
know my feelings i want desantis to stay
here in florida if trump wants it he's
got it so like is it all heading to that
we shall see but either way i don't
think hillary believes in the validity
of our election so she should probably
be sent to jail uh all right final and
fourth story uh is about dc because some
of these places they're just not
stopping when it comes to kobe they're
actually getting even worse
this is a tweet from dc mayor bowser she
says remember that starting saturday you
will need these three things before
heading out proof of vaccination 12
years or plus
proof of vaccination and photo id 18
years and over and a mask now it's
interesting the way she worded that to
head out she didn't say to go into
government property she didn't say to go
into a restaurant she said to head out
that you have to basically have your
papers that's what she's saying we know
none of this nonsense works we know that
the vaccines don't stop you from getting
coveted we know that the vaccines don't
stop you from spreading kovid
we know that people are just not paying
attention to these vaccines we know that
a higher percentage of black people have
not been vaccinated so is this racist we
also know that forcing someone to show a
vote uh some sort of photo id that's
we're always told that's racist if you
if you do it to make sure that people
are voting as the person that they say
they are but somehow uh if you show a
voter id or a photo id to walk into
mcdonald's you have to prove that you're
vaccinated but then you can eat the food
that'll make you fat which will make you
even sicker if you get cold
you guys get it yet you get it yet these
people are just ridiculous oh and of
course you know number three there was
the mass thing and it's like we're
they're telling us now that the masks
don't even work so now they've got
everybody in n95 so you just can't
breathe it's all insane so all this
leads me to this interesting compilation
video that i saw on twitter twitter just
about how badly the narrative has just
crumbled over the last two years take a
look i'm gonna shut down the virus i'm
going to shut down the virus look there
is no federal solution that vaccinated
people do not carry the virus don't get
sick not going to get coveted if you
have these vaccinations people who've
been vaccinated are unlikely to get
covas this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated that's why i'm moving
forward with vaccination requirements
wherever i can breakthrough infections
or breakthrough cases of covid19 we'll
leave vaccinated folks testing positive
that's going to be our new normal it
seems that more than half of the people
in the uk with the variant have been
double jabbed most are young people
under 40 years old nearly 80 percent
were vaccinated new concerns about the
omicron variants a record level of
children under the age of five are being
hospitalized amid a climbing infection
rates if you look at the children who
are hospitalized many of them are
hospitalized with covid
as opposed to because
of covid and they get counted
as a covet hospitalized individual when
in fact they may go in for a broken leg
so it's over counting the number of
children who are quote hospitalized with
covid if you're attacking me you're
really attacking science i mean
everybody knows that you're really
attacking not only dr anthony fauci
you're attacking science 95 affected
this is our show brought to you by
pfizer this is the jj vaccine that i'll
be taking so one
and done
americans will need a third shot fourth
shot another booster talk about people
getting a fourth four i thought we're
just talking about three so a fourth
dose we are looking forward be able to
vaccinate all these vulnerable people
brought to you by pfizer
you get it yet
do you get it
yet i know you do but maybe send that to
some of your friends and family that do
not get it yet i will end by saying one
last thing which is that if you have
stayed remotely sane
in the last two years i applaud you like
if you manage to do it if you manage not
to fall for all the pitfalls and the
traps they set up if you manage to
use your own brain and think things
through and make decisions for yourself
and not become a hysterical lunatic i
applaud you and i look forward to
continuing our relationship as we blaze
a trail to a freer saner
and better america than than we got
right now and i'm going to do it from
the free state of florida guys my full
interview with rand paul mostly about
fauci i mean rand paul has been smacking
him around
it's about fouchy and it's of course
about some big tech stuff as well that
is up on youtube and rumble right now
and if you want to play along you can
join us at reubenreport.locals.com
tomorrow is our last day here in newsmax
so once again i want to thank john
bachman specifically but the entire
newsmax team for hooking us up and
taking good care of us and uh if you
want to play along join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and next week
that's right we are finally back to the
live show at the new time 11 a.m
eastern from the house
and this is just the beginning
you